so I'm here in the beautiful small
mountain town of Netherland Colorado
where each year one very special
resident gets his own three-day
celebration and if all goes according to
plan
one day he'll be alive to appreciate it
this celebration brings in 15,000 people
to this small Colorado town during that
ere is live music
there is a purse parade there's a casket
race there is a frozen salmon toss and
icy water plunge and even a frozen
t-shirt contest whatever that is and
it's all to celebrate Grandpa Brett o
res he's known around here the frozen
dead guy
Brito was just a minor public official
living in Norway poking through the gays
his grandson trig be seen here in a 1994
story is a firm believer in chronics so
when Grandpa Brito died trig he had the
body cryonically preserved in California
later shipped to Netherland where he had
dreams of starting his own cryonics lab
so trick the bog I dug his house
Foundation and I said you know we need
to move that shed and he said well I can
but not today
and so well what's in that and he
said my grandfather my name is Brad and
I caretaker for retinal cells in icy
tomb here so this is the wooden I call
sarcophagus there are people from all
the world through this they come and
they're fascinated with the whole
concept of projects and people are
fascinated by the creepiness of it all
so it's just that kind of goes across
the whole spectrum of interests every
two weeks I have to go and pick up
crash staff from his casket
it's a rudimentary cryogenic technique
but it's no it has to do for his case so
the bossman is sealed been chained he's
not moved and frankly there you know no
one really knows why his condition is so
I don't exploit damn so much so I don't
do the tours like that now used to do in
the past I just I don't know what I'm
looking at it is a little bit more how
often some people do I guess if he was a
spirit in the universe I don't know if
he came around touch it any last words
stay cool
subscribe here and watch more videos